we have a voicemail number that you
should feel
more than welcome to call any time of
day
that number is 2192 david p here's a
good question asking about
about uh whatever became of the andrew
cuomo scandal in new york hi david
a quick question for you
[Music]
why are we hearing anything more about
andrew cuomo
the news every day a couple weeks ago
his allegation after allegation new
woman coming out saying that
he did something inappropriate now boom
gone i know this is a another on a long
line of
news stories that has dried up into the
ether
what's your take on it my take is not
that different
than what's been going on with matt
gates which is the matt gates story has
also
sort of taken a back seat i think
that there are these kind of lulls where
not l-u-l-z
right l-u-l-l-s to be clear um
we learn about an investigation and then
there's a period where the investigation
is happening
and unless there's something to keep the
story in the news corporate media just
lets it go
and my expectation is that um when
this all uh gets closer to a conclusion
or there is some
some final determination and i'm talking
both about matt gates
whether there will be charges and the
investigation into andrew cuomo
that it'll be back in the news i think
it's it's that simple uh there's other
shiny objects that corporate media has
moved on to
we will talk about the task of
fact-checking joe biden on today's bonus
show
kroger will also be starting drone
deliveries in ohio this week
what will it how will it look what will
it look like how will it work
and also the united states has started
to reunite some families separated at
the mexico border we will tell you how
it's being done
and what we can expect plus much more
including producer pat's
full fallout from vaccination
dose number two which he received
yesterday and born yesterday in the
morning
all of that and more on today's bonus
show
don't miss it get a membership at
joinpackman.com to get instant access
and i will see you then one of our
sponsors is vincero
watches giving you 15 off a high quality
wrist watch
is the perfect way to elevate your style
own at least one watch that makes you
feel great when you put it on you can
often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one year
return policy and
five year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store
and free shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman